du hast aber fünf minuten reichen nicht
um halt das ja zu finden
jo leute herzlich willkommen zu diesem
video und zwar folgen das ich bin gerade
ins büro gekommen brachte videos
schneiden dass jetzt gleich online
kommen wird größer ist mir aufgefallen
dass babys ein pc angelassen hat da sehr
freuen so sport gegangen ist und also er
ist gerade im fordert angelobt und er
hat gerade noch ab er hat gerade einfach
6600 er hat einfach 6600 wie wachs und
naja also leute ihr wisst ja so er hat
mich ja getränkt ist mein freund sie
kommen weitermachen möchte so geschockt
bin ist doch super und ich wurde auch
schon oft gefragt hey machen bank krank
machen frank ich dachte also ich muss
das jetzt auch wenn sie ein bisschen
schwerfällig muss das eigentlich machen
mit wie kommt jetzt auch jeden
augenblick zurück deswegen muss ich
nicht ein bisschen wie allen moment ich
glaub mal kurz in den gegenstand schauen
was ist hier denn so gibt also direkt
verschaffe den kaufen wir ihm das gleich
mal okay was gibt es noch ja kaum also
den skin volturi die bestimmt auch schon
mal haben
[Musik]
das war ganz toll war die post hat schon
üblich ist dass jetzt gerade kommt also
können wir direkt weiter machen ich habe
ihn jetzt dieses kind hier gekauft hat
jetzt auch nur noch 4600 libergs naja so
schnell sind 2000 wie bugs weg ich
schicke dem really auch da einfach mal
geschick den regeln einfach mit meinem
bild davon dass es sich dass er dann uli
bercks hat jetzt gucken wir mal also den
geist hier den kaufen wir ihm das schön
wir können auch direkt einen sprint
gehen wieder so aussieht also kommen es
ging hier ist ja wohl viel ja als der
skin hier
ich meine was will man auch mit dem wenn
man auch einfach mal diesen ultra ultra
gallens genannten können da ist auch
viel viel besser der passt auch viel
besser zu den flügeln kommt favorit
festlegen hier und weiß dass gegen
spanien alles klar was gibt es noch
gegenstand schon da haben wir einmal die
gene sperling ist ja noch so ein absolut
beschissen es gehen aber ich glaube
ihnen trotzdem weil also einfach also ja
okay was gibt es hier also er hat ja
noch 3000 ich muss jetzt mal ganz kurz
gucken dass ich dinge kauft ihr genau
3000 kosten damit ja auch wirklich null
hat also das kostet schon mal 2000 schon
mal sehr gut hier gibt es noch
accessoire für 800 dann hätte er aber
noch 250
ich kann maximal dafür sorgen dass er
nur noch 250 hat aber ich glaube das
reicht ja also ich glaube von 6600 auf
250 lohnt sich schon mal so was will
dann noch also er will auf jeden fall
die dunkle vorhut beste an dieser stelle
wobei vielleicht ganz gut dass gibt es
noch den weltraum hängegleiter also der
sieg geile da kann man sagen was im
bild.de ist auf jeden fall die pure
können
zuerst gibt noch zwei dinge die wir
kaufen können und zwar einmal diese tour
hatte hier die ist unfassbar geil also
erwerben
also ich nehme kurz für rebien video auf
ganz kurz muss man mit kurzen kemming
wir abstellen so ich rufe mal angucken
was er sagt
hey du weißt du noch hier bin
na ja also ich weiß nicht so irgendwie
hat mich darauf aufmerksam gemacht dass
ich mal im bett bringt machen sollte
siehst du witze aber fünf minuten
reichen dir ja nicht um halt das ja zu
kindern ich mein glück mal wasser dass
ich das gleich worten du hast hat dafür
zehn nicht ausgemacht habe schon
eigentlich siehst du das nur 7000 alles
gut ist ja halb so wild also und wird
doch mal du darfst jetzt also eigentlich
das ist ja nicht aussuchen es gibt nur
auf einen gegenstand die leistung kannst
aber es gibt hier
[Musik]
der scan ist auch richtig geil was
willst du denn damit er so richtig
nützlich
du hast ihn hat jetzt du hast etwas hat
nur noch 250 250
dann kann man sich jetzt gar nichts mehr
kaufen leider
nein es war verdient für diese da hinten
du hast ja nix also klar ist
gleichzeitig gehe dann jetzt auch lieber
nach hause in den nächsten minuten was
gehört auch ja gut aufgelegt so wird
dazu kriegt denkt das war auf jeden fall
jetzt ist notwendig weil ich habe jetzt
auch schon ein halbes jahr lang hier das
auf mir sitzen lassen die jagd auf ihn
zu wenn das fell ich habe alles gekauft
2038 die schönsten rosa sachen gekauft
ja da waren so gute sachen dabei diese
ganzen landes ins die einfach nur andere
paar farben hatten die folge bestätigt
wird wie richtige hast du das also ich
hab gerade sachen aus dem kühlschrank
rausgefahren die über gestanden haben
hat im mülleimer geworden und deswegen
stimmt jetzt hier draußen und
kühlschrank ich weiß was ich gemacht
habe seinen worten halt da kommt
aufgefunden und der war ganz alleine was
ein wirklicher bist du zufrieden mit der
sony ja ich vermisse ein bildschirm mit
dem ich mich sehr
also ich will mich nicht gesehen ich
möchte mich auch nicht auf jeden fall
mich jetzt seine 7000 jeweils ausgegeben
dass man aber ich muss jetzt denke ich
muss jetzt meinen tischtennisball in
mein ich muss jetzt los weil wir fünf
minuten da ist und deswegen will ich das
nicht miterleben
es macht es gut wenn ihr mich auf dieser
reise begleiten wollen dann lassen wir
gerne aber dann seht ihr noch ganz viele
andere videos ich mache eigentlich so
oft krank aber ich dachte das muss jetzt
einfach sein und dann sehen wir uns im
nächsten video wieder macht
ja